[Music]
Veronica is in Texas hi Veronica welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave I'm such
a fan sorry I'm nervous to talk to you
thank you for taking my call sure what
can I help
well a few years ago my mom needed
dental work and we had just moved in
with her and so I figured I might as
well help her so my husband got a credit
card for $9,000 out under his name it's
a medical credit card you can only use
it for ascetical things and she was
making the payments on it and she paid
it down to 5,000 the payments are like
250 a month and lately she's been
getting slower and slower with the
payments she would have faltered by now
but sometimes we'll pay it for her and
she pays it back the thing is we're
trying to get on the baby steps to get
out on our own and every time that we're
kind of ahead with her yeah we still
lived with her a little you can't get on
our feet well the first we've been here
for like I want to save five six years
because every time we get on our feet to
move out my mom's really bad with money
she does time and all your honey every
time and we will pay the payments or
come up with the payment or something
like we bail her out and then we're
stuck living here again and so this time
is a Betar everything so you stay yeah
that's yeah I move like even if we don't
immediately abolish don't you both have
jobs I stay home I have two babies my
husband works then what does your
husband make he makes about 30,000 go
get an apartment
okay and that are the credit card you're
not gonna do that okay as long as you
stay there as long as you stay there I
can help you as long as you stay there I
can't help you because you are in a
cycle you know what the cycle is and
you're refusing to deal with the cycle
every time you get ready to move out
your mother takes all your money and
you've been living there five freaking
years it's time to leave
now then you're going to end up paying
this dental credit card because you were
stupid enough to let to put it in your
name and do it you get to pay stupid tax
I've done a lot of stupid stuff in my
life and every time I write one of those
checks I call it stupid text you getting
ready to write a $5,000 stupid tax check
after you move out and work your own
debts no bond your husband's working
three jobs and you're working one this
is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]